[Music]
it's the place of dreams you almost
start to wonder ever actually exist as a
little kid you always hear about all
about your parents talk about it and it
just always use this magical paradise
listen you really want to come to this
is the world's best-kept secret right
but in here we have this magical world
[Music]
400 miles from Africa Aldabra sits like
a stepping stone in the Indian Ocean the
most remote of the Seychelles Islands
this is an isolated protected world
uninhabited save for the dozen Rangers
who fight to keep its pristine waters
wild and clean and free from human
impact but there's a problem
Aldabra is an amazing protected area but
you have limits and how much you keep
protected we're seeing stuff from all
over the world washing up on our shores
it's just some kind of terrible mistake
that this place has become the world's
rubbish dump it doesn't just stop at the
sea it ruins everything
it is us it is me you everyone it's
doing this to such an like pristine
environment that is untouched our waste
washing in polluting paradise
[Music]
it is done an endangered green turtle
her 100 eggs safely laid buried deep in
the sand holds herself back down the
beach past plastic
[Music]
minutes old hatchlings in the race for
their life to the scene
[Music]
their path strewn with plastic
[Music]
life for them is hard enough a unesco
world heritage site for nearly 40 years
our Dara's protected waters have made it
an ideal location for turtles to lay
their eggs the nesting holes peppered
the beaches but they accumulate and to
trap waste having an immediate impact on
the habits of this protected species so
me and the team are here today on beach
25 which is Aldabra and it's Tuesday the
26th and it's early in the morning and
we've just got to the beach and with
baseball during the night there was
about nine endangered green turtles that
came up or attempted to come and nest on
this beach and as you can see the crest
is actually covered in marine debris and
just two of those circles were actually
able
the rest of them got to these big piles
of trash and then just went back down
into the sea because they couldn't find
anywhere next in this land that time
forgot turtles are not the only large
reptiles affected Aldabra is home to the
biggest population of giant tortoises in
the world once nearly hunted to
extinction there are now a hundred and
fifty thousand of them long lived
animals now consuming our litter eating
some plastic several of our volunteers
have had to remove plastic from the
mouths of tortoises nuts to their
disgruntlement you can see he's made
some decent headway and so that you know
they don't have teeth but they do have
this very these very hard jaws you
certainly won't want to be bitten by one
and they can chomp their stuffing
underneath it and if this cat was on its
own and not attached to this bottle
you'd have a much better chance of
swallowing it it's not their natural
food item but they're not very
discriminators they're living on a very
in a very hostile environment there
isn't a lot of food and they have to
take their chance especially in the dry
season here which can be long they have
to really have a go at anything that
looks like it might be edible and that's
what they do so yeah unfortunately we
have seen them on many occasions having
a go at this plastic but this is a
tortoise poo if I turn it over you can
see that this tortoise has been chomping
away on one of those flip-flops and they
just don't understand that this is not
food and they will eat it
[Music]
so many people want to come here so many
people want to see its beauty and that
our trash ends up here it's just wrong
I think if we if we were to go back a
thousand years or even less you wouldn't
see this you would be able to look on a
sandy beach and you know you can just
walk and it's properly pristine I think
one of the things however is an amazing
protected area but you have limits on
how much you can protect it and whether
it's climate change where it's plastic
pollution it's showing that yeah you can
be a million miles away and you can
still have an impact on this place two
and a half billion people live in
nations that bound the shores of the
Indian Ocean in the west of the
Seychelles and the farthest plung of all
the islands is our Dabra a vast remote
at all its position makes it vulnerable
models show most of the plastic comes
from the east coast of Africa it's in
the path of the South Equatorial current
which sweeps plastic rubbish from
throughout the Indian Ocean towards
Aldabra but it's being drawn from the
east to from as far as Indonesia all
contributing to a plastic and pollution
problem threatening this treasure trove
of wildlife that brought us to Aldabra
as part of the nekton mission to explore
the deep ocean in this remotest part of
the planet this I have to say is the
first live television brought us that
anybody has done here where we are on
our Deborah at all the things they're
finding already in this plastics health
is children's shoes absolutely loads of
them as you can see plastic bottles we
know about the problem of plastic
bottles why there are so many flip-flops
that's been extraordinary they've
cleared the South island they found
50,000 flip-flops 50,000 flip-flops down
there dr. Lindsey Turnbull you are the
person that have driven this our Deborah
clean that project your volunteers are
working hard why was it so important to
do do you think well I think of you as
we said before if you have the privilege
to come here and it captures your heart
then you really cannot when you see this
it breaks your heart right this should
not be here it's an absolute travesty
and I really wanted to be part of the
solution although it was at the
Seychelles Islands Foundation who really
recognized this problem and I knew that
they needed to organize a massive effort
to get it cleaned up we thought it would
be really great to do
a collaborative project because it's a
global problem it's not the people of
the Seychelles who have put this rubbish
here this is not where it's come from
its global rubbish you know that
toothpaste toothbrush on the beach there
could be my toothbrush actually and I
think we do need to be part of the
solution they toil in the heat of the
tropical Sun of the Aldabra cleanup
volunteers from the Seychelles and from
Oxford University horrified by what
they've seen it look like the footage
that I've seen of a tsunami it was just
just because I mean it's just people
people you know just mounds and mounds
of the world's rubbish and people's
shoes I hear it's not it doesn't seem
right it's such a personal thing
people's shoes and you usually you used
to see in these piles of shoes because
there's a disaster happened and it's
just some kind of terrible mistake you
know that this place has become the
world's rubbish dump a UNESCO World
Heritage layer
I mean if you look at this right now it
looks like the middle this is the middle
of nowhere there's no ships on the
horizon there's no planes flying
overhead there's nobody for for hundreds
of miles and yet 50,000 flip-flops can
be collected by twelve people in two
weeks Jessie what are the sort of things
you found here I mean everything in
anything you can imagine that's ever
been made of plastic these are just some
toothbrushes you might recognize these
brands anything this is a part of a
North Face flip-flop this is the
packaging of a water bottle it's come
from Malaysia this is here all the
things that I find interesting this is
some orange juice wrapping that's also
come from let's come from Indonesia oh
and this is a king chess piece one of
our one of our other volunteers has
managed to have collect basically a full
chess set just from cleaning the beaches
it's devastating there's still the magic
around other rub that's seen the marine
litter just makes you read
straighted really angry that our
consumption it is us it is me you
everyone is doing this to such an like
pristine environment that is untouched
that first day when we were deployed
down to the south of the at all where
we'd be based for up to two weeks that's
when we saw the gravity of the situation
and it really was shocking I've never
seen so many flip-flops in one place in
my life you could see the impact that
was having on the habitat as well so
particularly for nesting Turtles you
could see the many obstacles and
obstructions that were in their way
before they even got to the sea
same with tortoises you could see just
where one was grazing by the grass there
was a piece of plastic very close to
them as well so it was very shocking I
mean this is a UNESCO World Heritage
Site is a pristine environment that's
where time stops in many ways when
you're here so to see this place that in
many ways is so unaffected by human life
affected by human life was really
shocking it's not just plastic that is
breaching Aldo burrows protected waters
teeming with apex predators this is a
healthy ecosystem founded on coral but
what will happen to this habitat if the
coral itself
is threatened by another global man-made
problem
this is a world of predator and prey
Aldabra swatters are home to at least
ten shark species the black tip reef
sharks glide through the shallows the
presence of these apex predators all
monitored by the Rangers
[Laughter]
[Music]
this is fish guts which we've collected
from fish taken in subsistence fishery
so it's a mixture of gills intestines
liver parts this is our fated remote
underwater video system as you can see
the bait canister here filled with fish
guts and the GoPro is just simple record
you'll drop down for about an hour then
we will retrieve it and then later on
when we're back on land that's when we
can look at the footage and see what's
been attracted to the bait we're looking
at species that are you don't often see
them wasps we're doing scuba diving so
they're quite easily disturbed and
they're quite there diver shy and also
their deeper than what we can dive in
some parts we see loads of different
species of shark tawny nurse sharks
sharp tooth lemon sharks gray reefs your
black tip reef sharks silver tips
sometimes if you're lucky hammerheads or
or tiger sharks sharks are a sign of a
thriving habitat with healthy coral
providing food and shelter for marine
creatures up and down the food chain
but the seychelles like reefs across the
world have been hit with warming oceans
devastating bleaching events have ripped
at the fabric of this coral community
like here cuza island near the most
populated part of the Seychelles where
much of the coral is dead when water is
too warm vibrant corals expelled the
plant-like organisms living in their
tissues causing Colin to turn white
smothered with algae some failed to
recover reefs thousands of years old can
be died within weeks the Seychelles lost
up to 90% of its coral in the most
recent bleaching event in 2016 but
Aldabra fared better than most Aldabra
is a huge marine protected area there's
no development along the coastlines
there's no fishing
there's no pollutants going into the
water here so the ecosystem is balanced
there's none no herbivores are being
taken out of the ecosystem as they are
in many of many other areas across
Seychelles were there fished and that
means that there's a healthy herbivore
you know parrotfish surgeonfish
and they're all grazing on the algae
that would soon overtake the reef after
a disturbance event like bleaching and
that allows the coral to then come back
much faster than it would if coral was
having to contend with this algae and
fight for the space on the reef the
importance of coral is everywhere to be
seen it is made of coral if the coral
starts to die eventually this place will
die it will weather let's walk you over
shall we - what is an ancient coral wall
and joining me here now is dr. Lindsey
Turnbull who is on the board of the
Seychelle Islands foundation who looks
after this extraordinary place but here
we have complete corals don't we it's
amazing yeah so this is probably about
125,000 years old and that's the last
time that this at all emerged so because
of changes in sea level they can
Koral can suddenly find itself lifted up
above and then of course it just dies so
this is fossilized coral and there's a
fabulous mushroom coral the entire thing
fossilized into the wall there sometimes
you can even see enormous fossilized
giant clams just part of these walls
spectacular but not fun to climb on on
or walk on it's part of the brutality of
this place
coral is literally the foundation for
islands like this if the coral dies
tropical islands will gradually
disappear buffeted eroded disintegrating
Aldabra has shown us that marine
protection is key
increasing coral resilience to global
warming events
this is an ocean nation 99% of its
territory is sea the Seychelles
government has pledged to place 30
percent of its oceans in marine
protected areas by 2020 it is a major
commitment with potentially broader
consequences these are not only
important for those coral reefs within
those marine protected areas but it has
the spillover effect and places like
Aldabra and other reefs within the
region may act as kind of nurseries and
you know places where coral will be able
to spew out that larvae to repopulate
those other areas which are not so lucky
and to be protected but you know may
ensure the persistence of coral reefs in
the future the fringing coral reefs hide
an enormous Lagoon the beating heart of
our Deb
in these shallow sheltered waters washed
by tides and life teams it is a pool of
creation I mean this is the world's
best-kept secret right but in here we
have this magical world mangroves
seagrass beds and corals all contribute
to a rich mix of habitats
all intact and all interacting it's for
the scientists that a goon is incredibly
special I think it's an incredibly
dynamic place it's constantly changing
and and it's pumping water in and out in
this living way almost like it is a
living breathing thing their wings
outstretched to 7 feet the circling
frigate birds give a sense of a
prehistoric world as red footed boobies
nest in the mangroves below
evolution on islands makes them
exceptional native species like the
Aldabra rail the only flightless bird in
the western Indian Ocean are testament
to their isolation it's an island lots
of things can't get here and in
particular and then alien predators
can't get here naturally and that allows
all kinds of mad experiments and
evolution to take place including
flightless birds
unfortunately when humans arrived they
came here to harvest the tortoises and
to harvest the Turtles but what they
brought with them were rats or cats were
pigs were goats and those things that
actually devastating to Island wildlife
eradicating any invasive species and
preventing more is a main aim for the
Rangers please clean any Footwear
both inside and out the few visitors are
warned the rules are strict vacuum and
clean all your bags
but the invasive species are arriving by
new means carried across the ocean on
plastic what's interesting about this as
you can see these from the way of the
degradation of this item and also the
fact that's got three large barnacle
shells growing on it this has been
floating around in the ocean for a very
long time it's not just about how it
washes up on the beaches and causes
problems here but it's bringing
something here we have an Aldabra an
invasive marine sponge for example and
that was used to be just found on the
island of Guam and gradually it has
suddenly spread across the Indian Ocean
it can smother coral but that's just one
example of something that's arrived we
don't know that it arrived on plastic
but it's possible that it arrived on
plastic or on fishing gear despite the
complete ban on fishing in the waters
around Aldabra evidence of it is
everywhere
phishing wrote by as a category by
itself it's the heaviest that we found
so far I think it accounts for about 60%
of all the marine debris we picked up it
basically gets washed up onto land and
like inland as well so then effect
sources the same Taurus is eating away a
rope it's it's terrible for their entire
soul because it doesn't just stop at the
seat it yeah it ruins everything
plastic pollution global warming both
reaching Aldabra strong defenses both
worldwide rubbish collected at high tide
it is shipped off isolated beaches
seasonal bad weather makes Aldabra
inaccessible for seven months of the
year they must work fast we know for
sure there's about 8 million tons of
plastic entering oceans over here and
you try and think of it in that sense
it's a it's a drop in a drop but over
here the main thing is to know that you
start in a process that you know this
stuff will end up back on our shores in
some ways
five weeks 50,000 flip-flops collected
25 tons of rubbish cleared the pristine
perfection of Aldabra a step closer the
ocean will bring more of our waste
washing inland was life will once again
be threatened
but for now Paradise Lost is being
restored
I had to appreciate how beautiful
somewhere is when it looks at midday a
little bit like a desert that someone's
turned into a rubbish dump and then when
the Sun count sunsets and all the
wildlife comes out the birds are flying
and the turtles coming out and you clean
that beach and suddenly it just looks
like the most stunning place in the
world it's easy to despair I think we
need to look at algebra as a symbol of
the plastics pollution and the marine
debris challenge that we have we also
need to switch the tap off there is
still a lot of plastic coming over to
algebra that's not of the Seychelles
doing but we're a country of under
100,000 people and we're seeing stuff
from all over the world washing up on
our shores
this truly is a global problem so in
order for us to address this problem we
need to have a global solution it's so
difficult people to grasp some of the
global challenges they don't have a face
they're too nebulous it's too big if we
can bring it down to this kind of scale
and make it personal all the challenges
that the planet faces are faced here on
algebra 2 we have the challenge of
plastic we have the challenge of global
warming we have the challenge of
invasive species actually if we can use
algebra as a metaphor for the world then
we can really algebra can have even more
global importance
you
[Music]
you